l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée de la proposition de loi
adoptée par le Sénat visant à renforcer
la prévention et la lutte contre
l'intensification et l'extension du
risque incendie la parole est à Madame
Dominique for ministre délégué chargé
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité
merci madame la Présidente
monsieur le Président cher Guillaume
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdames les députés Messieurs les
Députés je souhaite ici devant vous à
l'occasion de l'examen de cette loi
rendre avant tout un hommage sincère à
l'engagement des structures et personnes
mobilisées dans la prévention et la
lutte contre les incendies de forêts qui
sont déjà confrontés au premier feu de
cette année sur certains territoires je
pense notamment en Pyrénées-Orientales
aux Alpes-Maritimes et à la Corse
je veux remercier une nouvelle fois au
nom du gouvernement tous les acteurs
sapeurs-pompiers personnels de la
sécurité civile
sapeurshofter forestier sa peur
forestier bref toutes les personnes qui
s'engagent pour la sauvegarde de nos
forêts pour l'excellent travail qu'ils
effectuent au quotidien et pour leur
engagement
les incendies ont toujours existé dans
le sud de la France et une politique
volontariste de défense des forêts
contre l'incendie a été mise en place
dès les années 80 cette politique mise
en place dans les années 80 a produit de
très bons résultats en réussissant à
diviser par deux voir par 3 les surfaces
incendiées entre les années 80 et
aujourd'hui néanmoins le climat change
les incendies hors normes de l'été 2022
générés par un concours de sécheresse et
de température particulièrement élevée
ont constitué une preuve éclatante et
douloureuse des effets attendre du
changement climatique en matière de feu
de forêt il laisse entrevoir une
intensification du risque dans les
régions historiquement concernées du
sud-est du Sud-Ouest et de la Corse mais
aussi et surtout une extension du risque
dans des régions jusqu'ici préservées je
pense notamment aux régions de l'ouest
de l'est et du centre de la France
territoire dans lesquels nous n'avions
pas vu d'incendie de cette ampleur
auparavant plus de 72000 hectares
d'espaces naturels ont été détruits en
France l'année dernière mais cette
catastrophe touche l'ensemble des
territoires européens ainsi plus de
300.000 hectares sont partis en fumée à
titre d'exemple en Espagne en 2022
notre politique de prévention et de
lutte contre ces incendies doit donc
être renforcée et actualisé au regard
d'un risque amplifié et étendu sur
davantage de nos territoires je souhaite
ainsi saluer le travail du Parlement
avec le Sénat qui s'est saisi rapidement
de cet enjeu et qui a proposé et adopter
le 4 avril dernier cette proposition de
loi le gouvernement a décidé de
s'appuyer sur cet important travail en
inscrivant cette proposition de loi très
rapidement à l'agenda de l'Assemblée
nationale nos concitoyens attendent en
effet des réponses rapides des réponses
concrètes à leurs inquiétudes lorsqu'ils
voient les incendies parcourir de si
grandes superficie de forêts et dans les
quatre coins de la France
c'est la raison pour laquelle le
gouvernement a décidé d'engager la
procédure accélérée sur ce texte cette
proposition de loi montre la diversité
des politiques à conduire pour assurer
la défense des forêts contre l'incendie
ma présence devant vous aujourd'hui pour
représenter le gouvernement traduit le
caractère multidimensionnel de ce sujet
qui mobilise les compétences de trois
ministères le ministère de l'Intérieur
et des Outre-mer le ministère de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires et le ministère de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire le Gouvernement partage les
objectifs poursuivis de cette
proposition de loi le président de la
République a annoncé en octobre dernier
plusieurs mesures visant renforcées
notre politique nationale de défense des
forêts contre l'incendie tout d'abord la
prévention est demeure essentielles
notre stratégie est d'éviter le départ
de feu et d'être en mesure d'attaquer
les fenais sans pour éviter leur
propagation
des moyens supplémentaires ont ainsi été
accordé cette année par mon collègue
Marc féno à l'Office national des forêts
pour lui permettre de renforcer ses
missions de surveillance et de première
intervention et de les étendre dans les
territoires nouvellement concernés par
ce risque des moyens supplémentaires ont
également été apportées à l'Association
régionale de défense des forêts contre
les incendies des Landes de Gascogne
massif riches d'une organisation
impliquant les propriétaires forestiers
se renfort de moyens se poursuivra en
2024 mais il va falloir agir plus sur
l'origine des feux lorsqu'on sait que
90% des départs de feux de forêt sont
liés à une activité humaine notre
priorité d'agir sur les interfaces entre
forêt et habitation
soyons clairs les obligations légales de
débroussaillement fixés dans le Code
forestier doivent être mieux mis en
oeuvre alors qu'on estime qu'elles le
sont seulement à 30% pourtant leur
efficacité n'est plus à démontrer avec
Gérald Darmanin marcéno et Christophe
Béchu nous avons ainsi engagé des
actions au niveau national et au niveau
local pour sensibiliser le public
concerné pour accompagner les élus
locaux mais aussi pour sanctionner les
négligences volontaires cependant la
proposition de loi examiner ce jour va
permettre d'aller encore plus loin en
apportant des éléments utiles et
attendus de clarification de
simplification et de responsabilisation
nos moyens de lutte doivent en effet
être renforcés pour limiter la
propagation des feux protéger nos
concitoyens sécuriser nos
infrastructures
nous allons beaucoup évoquer aujourd'hui
la prévention qui est essentielle mais
malheureusement pas suffisante
malgré tout ce que l'on peut faire le
feu arrivera inévitablement malgré c'est
pour cela que la lutte doit également
être mieux organisée rendu la plus
efficace possible et que le Président de
la République a décidé de renforcer les
moyens terrestres et aériens cette année
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer l'adoption
par le Sénat de namendement du
gouvernement vise un reconnaître le
caractère dangereux du métier et des
missions exercées par les personnels
navigants de la sécurité civile comme la
loi le fait déjà pour les
sapeurs-pompiers professionnels depuis
cette reconnaissance symbolique est-elle
alors que l'ampleur de leur tâche ne
cesse de grandir
la proposition de loi qui est à l'ordre
du jour aujourd'hui présente des
évolutions plus que bienvenue il est
proposé en premier lieu l'inscription
dans la loi d'une stratégie nationale et
un terme ministérielle de défense des
forêts contre l'incendie qui permettra
de mobiliser pleinement et largement
l'ensemble des acteurs publics et privés
concernés la Task Force
interministérielle déjà mise en place
par le gouvernement sera missionné pour
l'élaborer et organiser les
concertations nécessaires le texte
proposé de faire évoluer la liste des
territoires réputés particulièrement
exposés au risque d'incendie ce qui
constitue un moyen d'être réactif face
aux évolutions du changement climatique
mais cette liste doit nous permettre
aussi d'assurer un déploiement efficace
de nos moyens de prévention et de lutte
vers les territoires reconnus comme les
plus exposés de même le texte suggère
d'améliorer l'articulation des mesures
de défense des forêts contre l'incendie
avec les autres politiques publiques
nous serons collectivement plus à même
de répondre aux devoir de lisibilité
pour les administrer si nous articulons
correctement cette politique avec les
politiques sur les sites classés ou sur
la protection de l'environnement
concernant la politique de l'urbanisme
je salue les propositions pour améliorer
l'information du grand public des élus
locaux et des futurs acheteurs sur la
sensibilité
aux dangers prévisible des feux de
forêts de végétation je pense aussi au
monde agricole qui a des solutions à
apporter que nous devons reconnaître et
accompagner notamment les coupures
agricoles lorsqu'elles sont
astucieusement positionnés par ailleurs
comme je disais précédemment les
obligations légales de débroussaillement
sont essentiels à mettre en oeuvre et le
texte prévoit des clarifications et des
simplifications utiles et attendues pour
améliorer nettement leur mise en oeuvre
je citerai deux exemples issus de vos
travaux en commission je salue la mesure
de simplification proposée par les
rapporteurs consistant à faire appliquer
les Old uniquement au droit de la
propriété lorsque les responsabilités
entre voisins se superposent et crée
l'inaction le texte adopté par les
commissions propose également d'étendre
les possibilités de création des
associations syndic ales autorisées les
fameuses ASA qui font la preuve de leur
utilité et de leur efficacité dans les
Landes de Gascogne et qui pourraient
s’avérer être une organisation cible
pour les massifs de forêts privés
ailleurs dans les autres territoires
je salue aussi la reprise dans cette
proposition de loi de ces deux
évolutions
issues de réflexion passée tenant dans
le cadre des Assises de la forêt du Bois
à savoir l'abaissement à 20 hectares de
l'obligation de disposer d'un plan
simple de gestion et la systématisation
de la télé déclaration la mise en place
d'un document de gestion durable est en
effet la première étape permettant un
propriétaire de connaître et de
maîtriser les risques pour sa forêt
enfin il est proposé l'inscription dans
la loi d'une journée nationale de la
résilience cette journée va nous
permettre de nous acculturer face à
l'ensemble des risques qu'ils soient
naturels technologique sanitaires bref
tous les risques et en particulier ceux
liés aux effets du changement climatique
en préparant l'ensemble de la population
en lui apprenant les gestes qui vont lui
permettre de se sauvegarder cela
permettra d'accroître encore
l'efficacité de notre sécurité civile et
de préserver des vies humaines
nos actions de prévention gagneront
ainsi en efficacité pour autant je tiens
à préciser un point crucial pour
l'examen de cette loi pour le
gouvernement il s'agit bien de rester à
une proposition qui traite strictement
de la prévention et de la lutte contre
les incendies et non d'avoir une loi
relative à la gestion forestière la
gestion forestière est un sujet bien
plus vaste que la simple prévention des
feux de forêt elle doit intégrer la
multi fonctionnalités des forêts les
forêts nous rendent en effet des
services précieux qu'il s'agisse de
services économiques en fournissant du
bois matériau et du bois énergie de
services environnementaux en termes de
biodiversité ou de stockage de carbone
de service sociétaux en termes de
loisirs et de paysages
elles sont nos forêts un atout
économique un atout environnemental un
atout social pour nos territoires ruraux
elles sont également une réponse pour
ces territoires à l'objectif de
neutralité carbone que nous nous fixons
pour 2050 la forêt est en effet le
deuxième puis de carbone après les
océans et elle produit des matériaux
renouvelables qui nous permettront de
décarboner notre industrie
pour tous ces services rendus dont nous
avons encore plus besoin de mains les
forêts doivent donc être défendues face
aux événements extérieurs et notamment
aux effets du changement climatique et
c'est là l'objet strict de cette loi la
question des enjeux d'environnement
d'économie dans la gestion forestière
plus généralement d'adaptation des
forêts au changement climatique ne
doivent être abordés aujourd'hui que
lorsqu'il y a un lien direct clair avec
les préventions des feux de forêt
autrement nous dénaturerions l'objet de
la loi et la demande des citoyens qu'il
apporte je le dis donc fermement cette
loi qui vise à des enjeux de sécurité
des biens et des personnes la prévention
et la lutte contre les incendies de
forêts ne doit pas servir de prétexte à
avancer des agendas de tels sur la
politique de gestion forestière ce ne
serait pas respectueux du travail des
femmes et des hommes sur le terrain en
ce moment pour juguler les incendies de
forêts en conclusion vous l'aurez
compris mesdames et messieurs les
députés cette proposition de loi sur la
prévention et la lutte contre les
incendies de forêt est un signal fort
envoyé aux propriétaires forestiers au
riverains des forêts aux associations de
protection de l'environnement aux élus
locaux et à tous ceux qui agissent avec
engagement au quotidien dans la
prévention et la lutte contre les
incendies de forêts il s'agit de leur
montrer que nous sommes capables
ensemble
d'avancer pour nous adapter au
changement climatique pour finir je
souhaite saluer la qualité du travail
des quatre commissions qui se sont
mobilisés pour l'examen de cette loi et
vous redire ma confiance sur le fait que
nous pouvons enrichir encore un peu ce
texte adopter il y a un mois par le
Sénat afin d'assurer cohérence et
efficacité dans les mesures proposées
dont nous partageons l'ensemble des
objectifs je vous remercie
merci merci
Madame la Ministre la parole est à
Madame Sophie panonnac leur rapporteur
de la commission des affaires
économiques
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le Président des de la
commission des affaires économiques
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues nous discutons
aujourd'hui à l'approche de l'été d'une
proposition de loi sur la prévention du
risque feu de forêt c'est une priorité
dans un contexte encore marqué par des
feux géants qui ont jalonné la saison
sèche en 2022 notamment en Gironde et
plus largement dans toute la France à
l'avenir le changement climatique
suscitera un stress hydrique régulier
une hausse du nombre de sécheresse
graves et augmentera globalement
l'exposition de 50% des forêts
françaises aux risques de feu d'ici 2050
ce sujet a été largement évoqué tout au
long de la mission d'information sur
l'adaptation au changement climatique de
la politique forestière et de la
restauration des milieux forestiers que
j'ai réalisé pour le compte de la
commission développement durable avec ma
collègue Catherine couturier je sais que
le texte que nous allons examiner peut
susciter quelques frustrations légitimes
sachez que nous traiterons les questions
de l'avenir de la gestion de nos forêts
dans une prochaine proposition de loi et
sachez également que de nouveaux moyens
budgétaires et financiers
intègreront très certainement le
prochain PLF je veux saluer et remercier
les sénateurs qui ont écrit et rapporté
ce texte et qui nous permettent ainsi de
nous saisir rapidement et efficacement
de dispositifs indispensables en
prévision d'un été annoncé à haut risque
avec mes collègues rapporteur de
l'Assemblée nous les avons auditionnés
et cet échange a été à révéler de
nombreux points de convergence cette
impression sort confortée du passage en
commission où nous avons adopté sans les
modifier de nombreux articles du Sénat
tout en apportant des ajouts conséquents
et je pense pertinents
le titre II qui m'a été confié traite de
la prévention des feux par la gestion
des espaces limitrophes entre la forêt
les zones urbaines et les
infrastructures nous le savons le
débroussaillement réglementaire joue à
cet effet un rôle majeur constituant la
mesure de prévention la plus efficace
contre les départs de feu et la
propagation des incendies je rappelle
que les obligations légales de
débroussaillement les Old s'impose dans
les zones particulièrement exposées au
risque incendie à toutes les
constructions situées à moins de 200
mètres des bois et forêts dont les
propriétaires doivent débroussailler une
surface jusqu'à 50 mètres autour de leur
bâtiment nous avons adopté une série de
mesures pour améliorer la mise en oeuvre
des old et les rendre plus efficaces en
prévoyant par exemple une
annexion plus systématique des old aux
documents d'urbanisme et des mesures
importantes de clarification juridique
sur le statut des old nous ajoutons
portés en commission sur la
mutualisation des travaux afin de
permettre une mise en oeuvre simplifiée
nous avons souhaité clarifier le régime
applicable en cas de superposition de LD
qui occasionne des confusions et
décourage la réalisation des travaux
nous avons également adopté des
modifications au régime applicables aux
installations ses vaisseaux nous devons
encore avancer pour le cas des réseaux
ferroviaires et je vous présenterai un
amendement en ce sens en outre le taux
de mise en oeuvre des eaux LD constitue
encore d'être trop bas et c'est l'un des
sujets sur lesquels il nous faut trouver
des solutions à la fois en termes
d'information de contrôle et de
sanctions je vous rappelle que 3
millions de propriétaires sont
directement concernés pour une
réalisation effective à peine
30%. le texte vient renforcer ses
obligations en conditionnant la mutation
des biens à la mise en oeuvre effective
de l'Old et en ajoutant les Old au
dispositif d'information acquéreurs
locataires liées à elle pour que chaque
qu'elle occupant connaissent ces
obligations il augmente aussi les
sanctions en cas de non-respect de ces
obligations que nous avons abondé en
commission nous avons également souhaité
compléter le texte en renforçant les
moyens techniques à la disposition des
collectivités pour contrôler la mise en
œuvre des old par l'usage de drone ces
moyens sont déjà utilisés pour la
surveillance du risque incendie afin de
signaler le départ des feux de forêt une
fois traité le sujet du
débroussaillement il faut admettre que
la construction aux abords des forêts
continuent d'être un problème c'est à
cette problématique que répondent les
prix les plans de prévention des risques
incendies de forêts ces plans
constituent l'approche la plus complète
pour amener armer un territoire face aux
incendies en matière d'urbanisme pour la
préparation des secours et la
sensibilisation des populations le
problème principal tient la longueur
d'élaborations des prises 3 ans en
moyenne ce qui explique que les
territoires en soi insuffisamment
couverts à ce jour seul 206 communes en
sont dotées depuis sa création en 2003
dans les compliqué on peut prévoir des
prises prescrits non et non approuvés 10
ans après pour cette raison aux articles
12 et 13 le Sénat a voulu simplifier et
amplifier la révision des prises la
Commission a donc adopté les évolutions
importantes à l'article 13 qui lui sont
remplacer le prix à créer une nouvelle
procédure intermédiaire plus simple plus
légère et donc plus rapide je termine
avec les autres dispositions du texte
que va vous présenter mon collègue Luc
lamiro merci nous souhaitons que tous
ces hypodytes que tous ces dispositifs
régulent mieux les interfaces entre les
forêts les activités humaines et servent
à davantage proposer protéger les
populations les forêts et leur
biodiversité contre l'extension du
risque incendie je vous remercie merci
Madame la rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Luc Lamirault
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
économiques
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues la forêt française
est un ajout un atout majeur pour notre
pays elle couvre 31% de notre territoire
et sa surface n'a fait que croître
durant la seconde moitié du 20e siècle
elle a ainsi progressé de plus de 20%
depuis 1985 pour atteindre aujourd'hui
environ 17 millions d'hectares
nous avons tous en tête les terribles
incendies de l'été 2022 qui ont détruit
72000 hectares de la forêt française
vous le versez la vie de milliers de nos
citoyens détruit la biodiversité et mis
en péril des activités économiques
les massifs forestiers sont de plus en
plus menacées par la propagation du
risque incendie et des régions autrefois
non concernées sont touchés par les feux
face à cette situation nous devons
améliorer les politiques publiques mises
en place en matière de prévention et de
gestion
aux côtés du renforcement des moyens
opérationnels annoncés par l'exécutif
des améliorations de notre droit sont
également nécessaires je salue le Sénat
pour son travail et je me fais félicite
que nous ayons pu inscrire ce texte
alors l'ordre du jour notre assemblée
est pleinement mobilisée sur ces
questions comment témoignent l'excellent
rapport sur la résilience de nos forêts
face aux changements climatiques de
notre rapporteur madame panonac
les titres 3 et 5 que j'ai l'honneur de
rapporter porte respectivement sur
l'amélioration de la gestion de la forêt
et de la civil cute et de la
sylviculture et la mobilisation du monde
agricole face aux risques d'incendie
le titre 3 de la présente proposition de
loin contient des mesures importantes
concernant les documents de gestion
durable de la forêt privée pour mémoire
celle-ci représente près de 12 millions
d'hectares dont 8 millions environ ne
sont à ce jour pas couverts par des
documents de gestion durable je me
réjouis que nous ayons adopté des
mesures utiles au stade de la Commission
en mentionnant explicitement l'enjeu du
risque incendie au sein des documents de
gestion durable et en abaissant le seuil
d'obligation à la mise de la mise en
œuvre de ces plans de gestion
de plus nous avons doté le Centre
national pour la propriété forestière
d'une vraie compétence sur la prévention
du risque incendie via la création d'un
réseau de référents DFCI
je souhaite qu'au cours de nos débats
nous puissions consolider les apports de
travail d'ores et des apports du travail
d'ores et déjà effectué qui a conduit
par exemple à expliciter l'enjeu de la
protection de la biodiversité lors de la
mise en place du bilan ami parcours des
plans simples de gestion et à insérer
utilement dans la loi une obligation de
transmission les schémas régionaux de
gestion silicone
OS 10
je salue à cette occasion tous les
acteurs qui concourent à la lutte contre
les incendies en France cette
proposition de loi vise aussi à les
assurer de notre soutien et de notre
volonté d'adapter le cadre juridique et
le cadre juridicule actuel à leurs
besoins face à la recrudescence des
incendies dans notre pays conséquence
parmi d'autres du changement climatique
le titre 5 de la proposition de loin
porte quant à lui sur le rôle majeur que
joue le monde agricole face au risque
incendie il faut rappeler que l'été
dernier les agriculteurs souvent
eux-mêmes touchés ce sont mobilisés en
nombre jour et nuit pour apporter de
l'eau débroussailler éteindre et
soutenir les professionnels sur le
terrain
le lien entre la bonne santé de
l'agriculture et la bonne santé de nos
forums forêt est intrinsèques la déprise
agricole limite l'entretien des
territoires et les coupures et
favorisent donc la propagation des
incendies à l'inverse des territoires
agricoles dynamiques constituent un
atout majeur de prévention du risque je
veux rappeler ici le rôle
particulièrement important de la
viticulture mais aussi des activités
silvo pastorales de ce point de vue les
efforts fournis et encore à fournir pour
favoriser le renouvellement des
générations l'attractivité des
professions et le partage du foncier
sont bien sûr essentiels du point de vue
de notre souveraineté alimentaire mais
aussi un rôle déterminant en matière de
lutte contre les incendies
je vais avoir du mal à finir donc je
vais
conclure en disant que nous avons
modifié l'article 25 et retravailler cet
article 25 pour favoriser le
développement des activités agricoles et
si vos pastorale en via un mécanisme de
contractualisation qui permettra
l'exonération du versement des
indemnités compensatrices et je souhaite
que nous puissions poursuivre
l'amélioration de ce texte tous ensemble
et je vous remercie merci
la parole est à Monsieur Anthony Bros
rapporteur pour avis de la commission du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le Président de la
Commission Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues le
changement climatique auquel nous
faisons face et sans précédent celle-ci
aura et a déjà une incidence
considérable sur l'ensemble de notre
société et notamment sur la biodiversité
afin de la préserver et de permettre à
l'ensemble des écosystèmes de ce
prémunir notre Parlement n'a pas attendu
et se mobilise à nouveau sur proposition
du Sénat la proposition de loi que nous
avons examiner cette semaine répond à
l'urgence que nous connaissons depuis
déjà plusieurs étés et même de plus en
plus tôt dans la saison commençons début
d’année dans ma circonscription dans le
Loiret bien qui est en situé au nord de
la Loire 5 hectares ont brûlé en forêt
d'Orléans au mois de mars compte tenu de
la sécheresse des sols
face à ce constat la commission du
développement durable et de
l'Aménagement du Territoire si vue
déléguer ces articles de cette
proposition de loi au Titre 1 4 et 6 la
semaine dernière nous avons pu examiner
146 amendements et en apporter et en
adopter 52 dont 17 provenant des groupes
de l'opposition parmi les modifications
apportées par des amendements de nos
collègues du groupe des Républicains une
attention particulière a été apportée
aux organisations professionnelles
agricoles ainsi qu'au pastoralisme
activité exercée notamment dans les
zones montagnes forestières
à l'initiative du groupe socialiste nous
avons adopté un amendement créant un
article additionnel afin de permettre le
transfert à un groupement de
collectivités la compétence de
réglementation en matière de défense
extérieure contre les incendies
il est en effet essentiel qu'au niveau
local en toute fluidité les exécutifs
puissent organiser pour mieux parés au
risque incendies c'est par la confiance
et l'adaptation aux réalités
territoriales que nous réussirons à
endiguer ces incendies j'en suis
convaincu c'est d'ailleurs en ce sens
que notre commission de manière
transpartisane encore une fois a jugé
bon d'associer au délégations à la
protection de la forêt les Présidents de
Conseils d'Administration des services
départementaux d'incendie et de secours
au regard de l'importance de la
coordination dans ce domaine
parce que la connaissance est la mère
des batailles nous avons sur proposition
du groupe socialiste et dans la ligne du
rapport présenté au début du mois par
notre collègue rapporteur Sophie
panonacle précisé que la recherche
appliquée devra contribuer à
l'élaboration d'une politique de
diversification des essences celle-ci
présente en effet l'avantage de ralentir
la progression des incendies comme nous
l'ont présenté les différents acteurs
auditionnés par la mission d'information
sur l'adaptation au changement
climatique de la politique forestière
s'agissant des aménagements à l'échelle
du massif nous avons renforcé le mariage
pour mener des actions de terrain inter
départemental contre les incendies
j'apporterai à ce titre des précisions
aux articles 3 et 21
la cartographie des voies d'accès aux
ressources forestières et des voies de
défense des bois et forêts contre
l'incendie constitue un élément
essentiel de cette lutte
l'identification des points d'eau fut un
apport important et je remercie mes
collègues de m'avoir suivi à ce sujet
tout comme je salue l'apport de nos
collègues du groupe écologiste dont
l'initiative a permis de garantir
l'accès à ces cartes via un portail
national commun
enfin notre commission s'est appelée à
promouvoir les outils destinés à une
meilleure sensibilisation de nos
concitoyens au risque incendie dans nos
forêts je tiens à vous rappeler mes
chers collègues que 9 départs de feux
sur 10 sont d'origine humaine soit par
l'activité économique soit par les
activités quotidiennes comme les mégots
de cigarettes ou les barbecues et feux
de camp on estime que plus de la moitié
est dû à des imprudences ou à des
comportements dangereux une prise de
conscience générale et rapide et dès
lors nécessaire
ainsi nous avons décidé de mobiliser la
filière rep-migo afin qu'elle participe
au financement des actions de
communication du ministère chargé de
l'environnement en faveur de la
prévention des incendies en forêt
une précision à l'article 30 ter adopté
sur proposition du groupe écologiste
afin que chaque collégien et lycéen
participeront sa scolarité à une journée
nationale de sensibilisation à la
sécurité civile enfin l'article 31 à
store une interdiction de fumer jusqu'à
200 mètres des bois et forêts les plus
exposés au risque incendie je
poursuivrai à l'instar de la commission
mon travail de conviction afin d'étendre
cette interdiction à l'ensemble des bois
et forêts du territoire national pour
améliorer la lisibilité de cette mesure
et sa portée pédagogique pour nos
concitoyens
mes chers collègues je souhaite que nos
débats venir pour les prochains jours se
poursuivre avec le même esprit
constructif que ceux en commission du
développement durable et de
l'aménagement du territoire et que le
fruit de nos travaux permet à l'ensemble
de la chaîne de prévention des incendies
et de luttes d'être mieux préparés à
Paris les incendies dans nos forêts je
vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Sophie maître
apporteur pour avis de la commission des
finances de l'économie générale et du
contrôle budgétaire
bonjour
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques madame et
Messieurs les rapporteurs au fond et
pour avis chers collègues
l'équation de la neutralité carbone a
moyen terme renforce puissamment
l'intérêt pour l'état de favoriser
globalement le secteur de lament
forestier et plus particulièrement
l'investissement et la gestion durable
des forêts privées alors que
traditionnellement la fonction
économique de la forêt est égarante de
ces autres fonctions en créant de la
valeur en vertu de la dage le bois paye
la forêt cet équilibre économique s'est
progressivement rompu la filière est
depuis au moins deux décennies en crise
structurelle entretenue par un
sous-investissement chronique et une
compétitivité insuffisante ces deux
citations sont extraites de deux
rapports publiés en avril 2020
respectivement par le Conseil Général de
l'alimentation de l'agriculture et des
espaces ruraux et par la Cour des
comptes cette dernière ayant été alors
saisie par la commission des finances
elle pose un diagnostic financier sur la
base duquel nous savons gré à nos
collègues sénateurs jean-baci
Anne-Catherine Loisier Pascal Martin et
Olivier Reichmann d'apporter des
réponses ambitieuses en complément des
mesures que les intervenants qui
viennent de me précéder à la tribune ont
évoqué concernant le renforcement de
l'obligation légale de débroussaillement
la dynamisation de la gestion sylvicole
avec l'abaissement du seuil des
laboration des plans simples la
sécurisation des travaux des
agriculteurs et je le souhaite le
soutien aux sapeurs-pompiers cette
proposition de loi comprend plusieurs
dispositions concernant le traitement
fiscal des travaux forestiers la
conditionnalité des aides publiques et
l'assurance des parcelles
il était légitime que la commission des
finances en soit délégataires et je
remercie son président son rapporteur
général et ses membres pour la qualité
des échanges tenus au cours de la
réunion où j'étais accueilli mercredi
dernier
deux articles ont été supprimés par la
commission des finances non à cause d'un
désaccord sur la pertinence de leur
dispositif mais pour une raison de
méthode le souci de la cohérence de nos
comptes publics appelle à rassembler les
révisions du 4 fiscal dans la loi de
finances et le fait de reconduire des
niches fiscales sans évaluation on n'est
pas de bonne pratique
cela revient à voter à l'aveugle
l'article 20 concernait le dispositif
d'encouragement fiscal à
l'investissement des filles en forêt qui
regroupent plusieurs catégories de
crédit d'impôts nous homologues au Sénat
ont rédigé leur propositions de loi
avant le dépôt de projet de loi de
finance PLF pour 2023 et l'ont déposé
juste avant son adoption or l'article 10
de la loi de finances a déjà
considérablement simplifié et étendue
ces aliments ces allégements de l'impôt
sur le revenu en réhaussant les surfaces
dans l'acquisition peut être soutenue
ainsi que l'ensemble des taux et des
maximas par contribuables ou par hectare
avant toute prolongation et tout nouveau
des plafonnement il convient d'attendre
de connaître la façon dont les
propriétaires forestiers s'approprient
la nouvelle mouture du défi certains
alinéas du texte du Sénat eau demeurant
aurait rendu inéligible les desserts
forestières ce qui n'est l'intention de
personnes
de même l'article 20 bis visé à
pérenniser un taux réduit de la taxe sur
la valeur ajoutée concernant certains
travaux silicole de deux choses l'une
oui la fin prochaine du plan de relance
point invité à une réflexion sur
l'opportunité de repousser d'un an son
bornage mais il faudra le faire de
manière éclairer cette automne je vous
informe donc que le président Coquerel
rapporteur général Cazeneuve et moi-même
avons écrit au ministre des Finances et
des comptes publics afin de disposer
d'ici au dépôt du PLF pour 2024 d'une
évaluation chiffrée précise du nombre de
bénéficiaires et du montant de
l'allègement prévu par l'article 279 du
code général des impôts
la commission des finances a par
l'insertion d'un article 35A et la
modification de l'article 35 conservez
l'idée du Sénat tenant à ce que soit
rappelé le principe de la subordination
du bénéfice des aides de l'État au
respect des objectifs de la politique
forestière nous avons donc placé la
mention de la défense contre les
incendies dans un article plus adéquat
du code forestier et retirer des items
satisfaits notamment depuis les travaux
de notre assemblée lors de l'examen du
projet de loi sur la lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique et la résilience
face à ses effets comme la
diversification des espèces et leur
adaptation au milieu
nous avons prévu à l'article 36 que le
Centre National de la Propriété
Forestière le CNPF n'est pas pour seul
interlocuteur les syndicats dans la
promotion de l'assurance mais l'ensemble
des structures chargées de la
représentation et du regroupement des
propriétaires forestiers dont les
associations et les coopératives nous
pourrions y ajouter les Chambres
d'agriculture l'enjeu est essentiel
aujourd'hui ne sont couverts que 800
environ 800 000 hectares sur les prix de
13 millions d'hectares de forêts privés
or les moyens publics ne suffiront pas
nous avons entendu associé un député et
un sénateur au conseil d'administration
du CNPF c'est le sens de l'article 36
bis adopté à l'initiative de nos
collègues Michel castellini et Charles
de Courson
la commission des finances a adopté
l'article 37 qui double le plafond des
dépôts autorisés sur un compte
d'investissement forestier et
d'assurance si chers collègues je me
réjouis de nos discussions à venir et de
l'amélioration du texte je vous remercie
merci
[Applaudissements]
je fais preuve de souplesse en ce début
de séance mais je rappelle que
l'expression des rapporteurs est limitée
à 5 minutes
la parole est à monsieur Guillaume
kazbariian président de la Commission
ah oui absolument et bien la parole est
à monsieur Éric Poget président
rapporteur de la commission des lois
constitutionnelles
de la législation et de l'administration
générale de la République Monsieur le
rapporteur je vous prie de m'excuser
madame la ministre monsieur le président
de la commission des affaires
économiques mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues nous
sommes réunis cet après-midi pour
examiner la proposition de loi déposée à
adoptée par le Sénat relative à la lutte
contre les incendies ce texte a fait
l'objet d'un concert sus remarquable
puisqu'il a été voté à l'unanimité par
nos collègues sénateurs il y a tout
juste un mois
renforcer les moyens dont dispose les
soldats du feu pour accomplir leur
mission suscite une approbation unanime
et légitime elle symbolise la
reconnaissance de la Nation pour
l'ensemble des femmes et des hommes
engagées dans la protection de notre
patrimoine et des populations à l'heure
où leur mobilisation s'avère plus que
jamais décisive
les terribles feux de forêt que notre
pays a connu l'été dernier dans son
hélas qu'une illustration parmi d'autres
ou encore aujourd'hui même dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales
cet esprit transpartisan a aussi guidé
nos travaux lors de l'examen du texte en
commission
s'agissant du titre 7 dont je suis le
rapporteur au nom de la commission des
lois nous avons renforcé la portée de
certains articles je pense par exemple à
l'exonération totale de la taxe sur les
carburants pour l'ensemble des véhicules
des 10 prévues par l'article 32 soit une
économie concrète de plusieurs dizaines
de millions d'euros en leur faveur nous
avons aussi adopté à l'initiative de nos
collègues Julien rancoul Julien Bayou et
Didier Lemaire des mesures
complémentaires afin de valoriser sous
différentes formes l'engagement des
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires et
professionnels
dans ce contexte
c'est véritablement avec stupéfaction
que j'ai découvert les amendements
déposés par le gouvernement vendredi
dernier
deux amendements de suppression ont
ainsi été déposés aux articles 32 et 33
alors même que le gouvernement n'en
avait pourtant déposé aucun sur ces deux
articles ni lors des débats au Sénat ni
lors de l'examen en commission la
semaine dernière
ces amendements balayent d'un revers de
main les travaux parlementaires dont
sont issus ces dispositions qu'il
s'agisse du rapport de nos collègues
sénateurs remis en août dernier ou des
préconisations que j'ai pu moi-même
formuler dans le cadre de la vie
budgétaire sur le programme sécurité
civile lors de la loi de finance 2023
il brise malheureusement le consensus
qui a su unir la plupart des groupes
politiques représentés au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée sur ces sujets il témoigne
surtout malheureusement d'une méthode
froide et technocratique qui méprisent
le Parlement malgré les échecs
politiques successifs que rencontrent
cette stratégie gouvernementale depuis
le début de la législature
pire ces amendements de suppression
visent en réalité à maintenir sur les 10
et sur l'ensemble des acteurs engagés
dans la lutte contre les incendies une
fiscalité à la fois injuste et
insupportable injuste parce que la
consommation de carburant par les
véhicules des pompiers et la conséquence
de leur activité croissante au service
de l'intérêt général c'est bien entendu
le cas de la taxe sur le gazole et sur
l'essence comme du malus écologique
applicable aux véhicules tout terrain
comment comment en effet accepter que
l'État engrange des recettes fiscales
sur le dos des 10 à mesure que les
hectares de végétation brûlent et que le
besoin en carburant de leur véhicule
augmente corrélativement
cette pression fiscale est aussi
insupportable parce qu'elle représente
des dizaines de millions d'euros annuels
qui pénalisent lourdement nos services
d'incendie de secours entravant leur
marge de manœuvre et mettant en péril
l'efficacité de leur action
nous aurons bien sûr des débats
approfondis sur ces articles lors de
l'examen de ses amendements y compris
sur l'article 34 relatif à la réduction
des cotisations patronales pour lequel
un meilleur encadrement du dispositif
est sans doute envisageable
mes chers collègues l'ensemble des
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires et
professionnels nous regardent
ils risquent chaque jour leur vie pour
protéger la nôtre notre devoir est de
les soutenir en utilisant tous les
leviers à la disposition du législateur
afin de les aider à remplir leur rôle
le poète Pierre Reverdy a écrit qu'il
n'existe pas d'amour mais simplement des
preuves d'amour alors avec ce texte nous
avons enfin l'occasion concrète de
montrer l'attachement que porte la
représentation nationale dans ces deux
chambres dans toute sa diversité à
celles et à ceux dont l'engagement
quotidien mérite un soutien plus que
jamais total et sincère je vous remercie
merci monsieur Roger
[Applaudissements]
et la parole est à monsieur Guillaume
kasbarian président de la commission des
affaires économiques
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
nous examinons aujourd'hui un texte qui
constitue une réponse nécessaire à un
besoin urgent celui de la protection de
notre forêt face aux grands incendies
qui menacent de se développer dans les
années à venir saluons avant toute
l'initiative de nos collègues sénateurs
sur ce sujet important qui nous
permettra je l'espère d'avoir un texte
promulgué avant l'été les feux de forêt
tentent en effet aujourd'hui c'est
indéniable à devenir des mégafeux plus
intenses plus fréquents il touche
désormais des territoires autrefois
épargnés par ces risques l'année
dernière plus de 785000 hectares
d'espaces naturels sont partis en
flamands en Europe dont 70 000 hectares
en France pour notre pays c'est un
niveau 6 fois supérieur à la moyenne
constatée ces 15 dernières années
ces feux se sont produits en Gironde
bien sûr mais aussi dans le Gard dans
les Bouches-du-Rhône dans les Landes et
même en Bretagne dans la Sarthe et dans
le Jura pour ne citer que les principaux
départements touchés les récents
incendies de Cerbère montrent que
malheureusement ces mégafeux risque de
se produire de plus en plus fréquemment
ces feux représentent évidemment des
catastrophes environnementales et
écologiques la faune et la flore
subissent des préjudices irrémédibles et
des millions de tonnes de CO2 sont
émises dans l'atmosphère mais ces feux
constituent aussi une tragédie pour les
hommes en Gironde des évacuations
préventives ont concerner près de 50 000
personnes 4000 bâtiments ont été menacés
heureusement grâce à l'intervention des
services de secours aucun décès n'a été
à déplorer et le feu n'a détruit qu'une
trentaine de bâtiments et 5 camping je
tiens à saluer au nom de la commission
et de toute la représentation nationale
l'action des soldats du feu et des
hommes et des femmes de la sécurité
civile qui au quotidien porte ce cours
aux habitants de nos territoires
leur engagement leur dévouement leur
sens du devoir suscite notre respect et
notre admiration pour les feux de
Gironde des pompiers sont venus de 60
départements de l'outre-mer et de cet
autre pays européens les mégafeux
menacent aussi nos activités économiques
je pense ici bien sûr aux activités
agricoles la porosité entre feux de
forêt et feux agricole étant de plus en
plus marqués mais je pense aussi aux
activités d'exploitation forestière car
la forêt est un secteur économique
particulièrement stratégique pour notre
pays ou pour encore les impacts sur le
tourisme tout ceci rend nécessaire de
renforcer l'efficacité des actions de
prévention et de gestion de ses feux les
enjeux abordés par ce texte sont ainsi
nombreux et transversaux et la
commission des affaires économiques à
laquelle ce texte a été renvoyé
logiquement sollicité la vie de trois
autres commissions permanentes pour
certains titres et articles je les
remercie et je salue le travail de leur
apporteur Anthony Bros pour la cddat
Sophie met pour la commission des
finances et Éric Poget pour la
commission des lois pour ceux ce qui
concerne plus particulièrement la
commission que je préside je souhaite
saluer l'excellent travail réalisé par
nos rapporteurs Sophie bananaque et Luc
lanniro tout en reconnaissant le solide
travail des sénateurs et en reprenant un
grand nombre de leurs articles ne
rapporteront su apporter des compléments
utiles ainsi notre commission a adopter
au total 155 amendements globalement je
me réjouis que l'ensemble des députés
est accueilli favorablement les
orientations du texte plusieurs sujets
très importants ont été très traités je
mentionnerai d'abord le rôle des
obligations légales de débroussaillement
premier rempart de la protection de nos
villes contre les incendies trop souvent
ignorées ou négligé ces obligations
sortiront renforcées et clarifier des
articles 8 et suivants fruits d'un
travail mené en bonne intelligence entre
les deux assemblées il nous faut
également être plus vigilant pour lutter
contre le déploiement d'une urbanisation
qui ne connaît pas ses limites la lutte
contre les constructions illicites est
un sujet qui me tient toujours à coeur
et c'est pourquoi je souhaite tout
particulièrement saluer le travail de
Sophie panonac à ce sujet à l'article 13
notamment qui viendra renforcer les
règles sur l'ex des constructions en
zone forestière je souhaite enfin
insister sur le titre 5 qui porte sur la
mobilisation du monde agricole face aux
risques incendies rappelons-le la
solidarité du monde rural a été
exemplaire lors des incendies de l'été
dernier les agriculteurs se sont
mobilisés pour apporter de l'eau aux
pompiers mais aussi des victuailles pour
soutenir moralement les pompiers et nos
concitoyens touchés Luc Lamirault l'a
rappelé le destin de notre agriculture
et de nos forêts sont liés nous le
savons la déprise agricole est un risque
pour notre souveraineté alimentaire elle
est aussi un risque face aux incendies
car l'agriculture peut jouer un rôle de
pare-feu très important dans les zones
majoritairement forestières je me
réjouis que notre commission est
consolidée les apports du Sénat à ce
sujet notamment à l'article 25 en
prévoyant la mise en place de contrats
agricoles ou pastoraux pour lutter
contre les incendies chers collègues je
souhaite que nous puissions avancer
ensemble sur ce texte dont les objectifs
peuvent j'en suis persuadé tous nous
réunir je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
le président et nous abordons la
discussion générale sur ce texte la
parole est à Monsieur Stéphane
delautraite pour le groupe socialiste et
apparenté
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mesdames Messieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur le Président de la
commission économique mes chers
collègues permettez-moi un préambule
d'adresser quelques mots de gratitude et
de reconnaissance aux sapeurs-pompiers
professionnels comme volontaire qui
était en première ligne face au feu de
forêt de cet été et qui poursuivent leur
engagement chaque jour dans la lutte
contre les incendies
mener en pleine saison du feu les
travaux de nos collègues sénateurs ont
rapidement permis la publication d'un
rapport portant sur les mesures à
prendre pour anticiper les risques à
venir
celui-ci est sans appel sur la nécessité
d'adapter nos politiques de gestion
forestière à l'évolution du climat face
à l'intensification du rythme des
événements climatiques extrêmes mais
aussi à la nécessité de s'emparer dès
aujourd'hui des enjeux de prévention et
de résilience cette proposition
consensuelle du Sénat est plus que
bienvenue je veux d'abord saluer le
travers les travaux de nos rapporteurs
qui nous ont permis d'apporter de
premières améliorations au texte au
stade des commissions participant ainsi
de ce que j'ai appelé en commission un
beau continuum parlementaire dans les
différentes commissions saisies les
débats en effet étaient qualifiés
permettant ainsi d'aller plus loin dans
la coordination entre la stratégie
nationale de attention des incendies
avec les différents documents de gestion
du risque incendie de renforcer les
obligations légales de débroussaillement
et les sanctions associés mais aussi de
placer les 10 et pompiers volontaires au
cœur du dispositif d'information
cependant à l'issue des débats il
apparaît il apparaît que le texte se
concentre davantage sur la prise en
compte du risque à court terme au risque
de négliger le nécessaire travail de
résilience face aux évolutions du climat
le groupe socialiste continuera donc de
porter des propositions complémentaires
pour aller plus loin en ce sens et
déplore l'approche l'absence d'approche
scientifique je pense en particulier aux
recommandations du Haut Conseil pour le
climat dans la gestion et la
préservation des puits de carbone que
représente les forêts d'autre part il
nous faut désormais assumer un discours
clair face aux pratiques les moins
vertueuses en combat en combattant la
multiplication des monocultures
et en inscrivant la lutte contre les
feux de forêt au sommet des
préoccupations de l'État dans
l'organisation des surfaces boisées
alors certes nous l'avons entendu en
commission c'est compliqué d'intégrer
l'ensemble de ces considérations dans
les dispositifs vous avez précisé dans
votre propos du linéaire madame la
rapporteur que le temps viendra d'un
acte 2 sur la gestion de nos forêts mais
quel dommage mes chers collègues de
remettre à plus tard ce que nous
pourrions inscrire dès aujourd'hui dès
aujourd'hui dans la loi c'est pourquoi
le groupe des élus socialistes est
apparentés fidèle à son engagement
constant sur le sujet poursuivra son
travail en proposant de nouveaux
amendements
ce que nous appelons de nos vœux c'est
d'abord de poursuivre les efforts pour
intégrer à tous les documents
administratifs des objectifs de
diversification des essences
en abordant et en favorisant un taux
minimum d'essence de bois feuillus pour
limiter les risques en amont c'est
ensuite d'examiner ensemble des pistes
envisageables pour renforcer le
financement des 10 et je ne reprendrai
pas les propos de notre collègue
rapporteur mais c'est aussi d'engager
une bifurcation sur la trajectoire
budgétaire des agences de l'État en
charge de la prévention des risques je
pense notamment à l'ONF à Météo France
mais aussi au cerema
sur ces différentes dimensions de la
proposition de loi il y a encore
beaucoup à faire mais je suis convaincu
que la suite de nos débats sera
l'occasion de remettre sur le métier ces
travaux cruciaux et de trouver des
solutions utiles pour nos
sapeurs-pompiers comme pour les
territoires concernés vous pourrez donc
compter sur le groupe socialiste pour
traduire les orientations de ce projet
de loi dans le prochain projet de loi de
finances qu'il s'agisse des recrutements
ou des moyens mais parce que nous sommes
sensibles aux avancées que propose ce
texte et sous réserve de son évolution
le groupe des élus socialistes et
apparentés soutiendra ce texte je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Didier Le Maire
pour le groupe horizon et parenté
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers et chers
collègues
les feux que nous avons subi à l'été
2022 nous ont permis de mettre en
lumière un certain nombre de faiblesses
des politiques de prévention de lutte
contre les incendies or en matière de
gestion de crise la prévention et son
meilleur à tout
Gironde
Drôme Corse Aveyron Lozère mais aussi
Bretagne Maine-et-Loire Jura Vosges et à
l'instant où nous parlons ici même dans
cette hémicycle un risque très sévère
très important dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales qui sont en attente
de renfort
aucun territoire n'était épargné par
l'extension du risque d'incendie
aujourd'hui plus intense qu'il était
auparavant mais également plus étendu
géographiquement et temporellement et
qui concerne tant la végétation que les
terres agricoles
un incendie est une catastrophe humaine
mais aussi naturelle et économique
depuis le début de l'année 2023 ce sont
d'ores et déjà 207 incendie qui ont été
recensés
en France 90% des incendies sont
d'origine humaine mais le changement
climatique accélère les conditions
propices de leur intensité dès lors rien
ne saurait remplacer une politique de
prévention volontariste et efficace la
proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui permettra d'y participer
la semaine passée nous avons célébré la
journée internationale des
sapeurs-pompiers puis la Journée de
l'Europe
l'été dernier c'est sur le terrain qu'il
se retrouvait en effet la France a
activé pour la première fois le
mécanisme de protection civile de
l'Union européenne ce sont 8 avions
bombardiers d’eau Grey italiens et
suédois ainsi que 360 personnes
allemandes autrichiennes polonaise et
roumaine venu nous aider à maîtriser
puis éteindre les feux qui dévastaient
notre territoire en dépit de ce soutien
les feux que nous avons vécu ont été
dévastateurs et entraînés pardon
l'évacuation de milliers de riverains et
de vacanciers qui ont pu être prise en
charge grâce aux associations de
sécurité civile aux élus citoyennes et
citoyens engagés
sur ce dernier point je tiens à dire ici
la reconnaissance de la Nation à
l'endroit de celles et ceux qui risquent
leur vie pour nous protéger nos
sapeurs-pompiers qui partout sur le
terrain assure un travail formidable au
service de l'intérêt général et qui
mérite qu'on soit leur côté toute
l'année et pas seulement lorsqu'ils font
la une de l'actualité
un sentiment que j'entendais encore il y
a moins d'un an lorsque moi-même je
servais cette belle corporation des
sapeurs-pompiers c'est aujourd'hui à eux
que je pense mes collègues
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires
professionnels et militaire
soutenir les sapeurs-pompiers à travers
les services départementaux d'incendie
et de secours c'est soutenir notre
modèle de sécurité civile au bénéfice de
nos concitoyennes et concitoyens sur
l'ensemble de notre territoire qu'il
soit rural ou urbain l'initiative
législative de nos collègues sénateurs
et sénatrices doivent être salué elle
vient d'ailleurs compléter les
nombreuses mesures lancées par le
gouvernement ces derniers mois et les
avancées qui ont permis la loi Matra
à la croisée des enjeux de sécurité
d'aménagement du territoire des finances
publiques des politiques agricoles le
domaine de la sécurité civile est vaste
et impose d'être traité de façon
interministérielle sous le regard croisé
de nos différentes commissies de notre
commission pardon ici ici même au
Parlement à ce sujet je tiens à saluer
le travail effectué en commission sur ce
texte et particulièrement celui de mes
collègues Luc lamero Xavier Albertini 20
sentier beau et François Jolivet
le groupe Horizon a défendu et fait
adopter des amendements qui permettent
par exemple de renforcer l'effectivité
de la mise en application des
obligations légales de débroussaillement
ou encore de clarifier l'indemnisation
par les assurances des coupes tactiques
ce texte permet d'apporter une réponse
forte nécessaire et attendue par les
acteurs de terrain
le groupe horizon et apparenté partage
l'esprit et les mesures portées par ce
texte de loi et soutiendra les avancées
qu'il contient je vous remercie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Madame Marie pochon pour
le groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur dame les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues il nous faut faire
une pause réglementaire sur les
contraintes environnementales la semaine
dernière le président de la République
nous appelait donc à faire une pause
l'environnement ça commence à bien faire
deux jours deux jours après que la
France célèbre tristement son jour du
dépassement ces contraintes
environnementales elles nous sont
connues aujourd'hui ce sont les risques
climatiques qui fragilisent les murs de
nos maisons ils n'ont nos caves à sèche
nos champs et nos cours d'eau ce sont
les pluies qui ne tombent plus c'est la
sixième extinction de masse des espèces
ce sont les incendies qui ravagent nos
forêts obligés de cette loi
on ne fait pas de pause avec la
catastrophe écologique en cours elle
s'impose tout simplement à nous
cette loi est celle d'une nation
traumatisée rester sous le choc de
l'ampleur des incendies qui ont ravagé
son pays les ces derniers environ 66000
hectares de forêts
291 feux au total
nous voyons déjà ceux qui se profile en
ce printemps sans eau alors que mes
commencent tout juste déjà 207 incendies
ont été enregistrés en 2023
vous savez ce qu'il faut pour déclencher
un feu de forêt une température de plus
de 30 degrés moins de 30% d'hydrométrie
plus de 30 km/h devant c'est la règle
des 3 30 bien connue des
sapeurs-pompiers qui au vu des impacts
des changements climatiques nous dicte
l'urgence d'anticiper pour protéger nos
forêts à cela s'ajoute un facteur le
facteur humain celui-là même qui est à
l'origine de 90% des feux du fait de ses
activités celui-là même sur lequel nous
pouvons agir nous législateurs en posant
des moyens une meilleure planification
des services des outils pour une culture
commune de la sécurité civile et en
posant oui mes chers collègues d'énormes
des normes environnementales des
objectifs climatiques tenus qui
protègent nos forêts et la vie
cette proposition de Loire renforce la
capacité de l'état de ses services de la
sécurité civile de la population pour
prévenir et lutter contre le risque
incendie elle pose les bases d'une
stratégie nationale interministérielle
elle abaisse le seuil pour les
laboration d'un plan simple de gestion
pour les forêts privées elle pose la
nécessité d'une carte d'alléa pour
cartographier le risque d'incendie oui
comme je l'ai déjà soulevé en commission
cette proposition de loi est bien elle
se situe dans la droite ligne de
l'histoire de la sécurité civile à la
française c'est à dire qu'on attend de
vivre collectivement un drame comme les
incendies monstres de l'été dernier pour
renforcer les moyens ou modifier le
droit positif cependant mes chers
collègues elle ne proposent aucun
changement de modèle aucune remise à
plat des moyens que ce soit pour le
réarmement de l'ONF ou la reconnaissance
due aux sapeurs-pompiers volontaires que
nous avons tant de mal à recruter
partout dans nos campagnes
le rôle vital devrait être reconnu et
pleinement valorisé plutôt que d'être
balayée tantôt par 49,3 tantôt pour
irrecevabilité face à la plus grande
crise que l'humanité doit affronter oui
cette proposition de loi pourrait être
mieux poser comme préalable à la
prévention et la lutte contre
l'intensification des incendies
l'urgence de la reconnaissance par la
nation des volontaires de la sécurité
civile l'urgence de remettre de l'humain
dans la politique forestière et de
gestion des risques l'urgence de changer
de modèle dans la gestion de nos forêts
sont autant d'impérieuses nécessité si
nous voulons éviter les urgences de
demain chers collègues en France
aujourd'hui la sylviculture intensive
est productiviste en monoculture se
développe tout comme les couperases
mettant en danger les puits de carbone
et de biodiversité que sont nos forêts
nous écologistes porterons de nouveau
pendant cette séance un certain nombre
de propositions de bon sens étayées
scientifiquement pour une meilleure
gestion des forêts pour que celle-ci
soit résiliente aux incendies
conformément aux préconisations de la
mission d'information conduite par mes
collègues mesdames panonacle et
couturiers que vous refusez pour le
moment d'intégrer cela veut dire tenir
compte du caractère propice à une
propagation du feu dans le choix des
essences en cas de plantations poser des
critères de diversification des essences
de préservation des services
écosystémiques dans les schémas de
gestion cylvicole ou interdire hormona
sanitaire les couperas de plus de deux
hectares
déjà nous avons garanti en commission
l'inclusion des organisations pastorales
si essentielles dans l'élaboration de la
stratégie de prévention et de lutte
contre les incendies je me félicite
aussi et je nous félicite de
l'instauration d'une journée nationale
de sensibilisation à la sécurité civile
dans les collèges que nous écologistes
avons fait adopter en commission
nous devons renforcer la culture commune
de la sécurité civile et au-delà de
moyens et de reconnaissance pour ces
millions de sapeurs-pompiers qui nous
protègent et protègent le vivant comme
un des derniers services publics sur nos
territoires ruraux nous devons tout
faire pour susciter des vocations
valoriser l'engagement au service du
bien commun
chers collègues les défis devant nous
sont immenses et nous nous devons d'être
celles et ceux qui auront pris leur
responsabilité lorsque les forêts
brûlées sous nos yeux c'est aussi
évident que cette dernière question est
vertigineuse comment éteindre un
incendie quand il n'y a plus d'eau
alors oui nous écologiste portons un
regard bienveillant sur ce texte mais
nous espérons que cette loi puisse au vu
des crises qui seront devant nous dans
les années à venir être celle qui
bouscule un peu les traditions pour
qu'en 2023 le vote de la loi à la
française pour la sécurité civile soit
enfin celui de l'anticipation je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Yannick Monnet
pour le groupe de la Gauche démocrate et
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre chers collègues notre groupe se
réjouit de l'inscription de ce texte
alors du jour de notre assemblée
après les foyers au bilan des incidents
des incendies pardon de l'an dernier à
l'échelle de la France mais aussi de
l'Europe l'adaptation de la stratégie
française de prévention et de lutte
contre les incendies de forêt est devenu
une urgence nécessité
la durée d'intensité des vagues de
chaleur qui frappent régulièrement notre
continent la récurrence des épisodes de
sécheresse impose de procéder à réexamen
critique de l'efficience de notre
politique de sécurité civile
le texte qui nous est soumis présente à
cet égard l'indéniable avantage de
mettre le pied dans la porte en
proposant des mesures d'adaptation qui
vont dans le bon sens et contribuer à
débroussailler le maquis administratif
actuel à cet égard nous ne pourrons bien
sûr qu'accueillir favorablement la
définition d'une véritable stratégie
interministérielle visant à mieux
coordonner au plan national la lutte
contre les feux de forêts
nous regrettons cependant comme d'autres
que cette stratégie ne s'adosse à un
plan plus général d'adaptation de la
forêt au changement climatique afin de
permettre à la forêt française de jouer
pleinement son rôle dans l'atténuation
du réchauffement et de ses conséquences
nous partageons néanmoins la volonté que
traduit ce texte d'intégrer de manière
plus large des instruments de
planification nous saluons aussi le
renforcement des obligations légales de
débroussaillement nous partageons enfin
la nécessité d'un renforcement de la
sensibilisation des citoyens élus et
professionnels concernés pour autant si
les objectifs de ce texte sont louables
les moyens restent insuffisants et les
amendements de suppression du
gouvernement déposés ce week-end sur
l'exonération de la taxe sur les
carburants montre que vous n'avez pas
pris la mesure des besoins nécessaires
en matière de lutte contre les incendies
l'extension géographique des incendies
mais dès à présent à mal les échanges
inter départementaux la Fédération
nationale des sapeurs-pompiers appellent
en conséquence à atteindre le nombre
nous le savons de 250 000 sapeurs
volontaires d'ici 2027 contre 197000
actuellement le chef de l'État a pris
des engagements en ce sens et le
présente instaure un dispositif de prise
en charge par l'État des cotisations
patronales c'est une avancée en faveur
de la reconnaissance et la valorisation
de l'engagement de ces hommes et femmes
il faut aller plus loin et valoriser cet
engagement dans leur parcours
professionnel et de formation il importe
également que cette armée de réserve si
précieuse des volontaires ne servent pas
de prétexte pour baisser le budget des
toujours en matière de moyens les
sapeurs-pompiers soulignent entre autres
exemples insuffisance du parc de
camion-citerne forestiers il chiffre les
besoins à 10 000 camions compte 3700
actuellement avec un coût unitaire moyen
de 300.000 euros cet investissement sera
inatteignable pour les 10 le chef de
l'État a promis des moyens
supplémentaires d'investissement à
hauteur de 150 millions d'euros soit à
peine 10% des investissements des seuls
camions-citerne il est donc
indispensable de nous doter d'une
programmation financière autrement
ambitieuse sur le terrain de la
prévention là aussi les moyens manquent
nous le voyons dans le recul préoccupant
du service public forestier l'ONF a
perdu plus du tiers de ses effectifs en
20 ans
il en résulte que les surfaces de forêt
à gérer par chaque agent ont doublé au
détriment des missions de surveillance
de départ de feu de suivi sanitaire des
peuplements de contrôle de l'application
de la réglementation les syndicats
réclament avec nous depuis des années
sans être entendu le retour à minima au
niveau des effectifs de 2011
à cela s'ajoute le fait que la majeure
partie de la forêt française est
aujourd'hui détenu par des propriétaires
privés qui ne se voient pas imposer les
mêmes obligations en matière de gestion
durable et de protection de
l'environnement
les choses évoluent mais la question se
pose néanmoins de doter l'ONF de moyens
d'intervention plus large afin de lui
permettre le cas échéant de gérer ou
co-géré une part plus importante de
notre patrimoine forestier
autrement dit
si le présente met un pied dans la porte
il appartient désormais à l'exécutif de
l'ouvrir entièrement en dotant les 10
l'ONF mais aussi le CNPF ou encore Météo
France des moyens matériels et humains
nécessaires à l'accomplissement de leur
mission
sous le bénéfice de ces observations
nous pardon nous abordons ce débat dans
un esprit constructif convaincu que la
prévention et la lutte contre les
incendies de forêts ne seraient efficace
que si nous y consacrons non seulement
des moyens juridiques et
organisationnels adaptés mais encore
humain et financier je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur dinosinieri
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur un rapport
sénatorial remis à l'été 2022 après
conduisait plusieurs dispositifs pour
mieux prévenir et lutter contre les
mégafeux qui se multiplient ces
dernières années à cause du
réchauffement climatique la proposition
de loi que nous examinons aujourd'hui
traduit plusieurs de ses recommandations
les sénateurs ont mis en évidence des
perspectives inquiétantes en Provence
les surfaces brûlées pourraient
augmenter de 80% d'ici 2050 près de 50%
des Landes et forêt pour être concernée
par un risque incendié élevé comme un
tiers en 2010 enfin la période à risque
fort sera trois fois plus longue avec
des feuilles hivernaux qui devraient eux
aussi augmenter
l'efficacité de notre stratégie actuelle
de lutte qui a fait de la France un
modèle partout en Europe et dans le
monde ne suffira donc pas à faire face à
l'augmentation du risque incendie et
notamment à l'émergence de feu hors
normes particulièrement diffusé à
maîtriser tels qu'adopter et enrichi par
les sénateurs la proposition de loi à
huit grands objectifs
élaborer une stratégie nationale et
interministérielle mieux réguler les
interfaces forêts zone urbaines
dynamiser la gestion des forêts et
promouvoir la sylviculture face aux
risques incendie améliorer l'aménagement
des massifs forestiers mobiliser le
monde agricole
sensibiliser les populations équipées
les sapeurs-pompiers à la hauteur des
besoins et enfin revoisez les parcelles
brûlées et financer la reconstitution de
forêt plus résilience
9 feux de forêt sur 10 on l’eau
d'origine humaine qu'il soit
intentionnelle ou accidentelle c'est
pourquoi parmi les mesures phares le
texte consacre notamment au niveau
législatif l'interdiction de fumer dans
un bois ou une forêt classée à risque
d'incendie il renforce et clarifie
également l'obligation légale de
débroussaillement les sénateurs ont
approuvé largement les grandes lignes du
texte initial en y apportant toutefois
quelques modifications
ils ont ainsi confirmé le rôle essentiel
des sylviculteurs et des agriculteurs
dans la prévention elles ont intégré la
stratégie nationale et
interministérielle incendie dans notre
politique de gestion de l'eau et de
protection de la biodiversité enfin ils
ont tenu à renforcer le caractère
dissuasif des sanctions nous devons
définir une politique publique globale
et cohérente qui puisse décliner dans
les territoires en s'adaptant alors
particularité ce texte est adapté aux
réalités du terrain dans les
républicains se font sans cesse d'écho
cette initiative de nos collègues
sénateurs a en parallèle permis de faire
prendre conscience de l'urgence au
gouvernement qui tardait à prendre les
mesures fortes et rapides qui se faisait
attendre
ainsi en avril une semaine après
l'adoption de cette proposition de loi
au Sénat le gouvernement a présenté son
dispositif contre les feux de forêt les
moyens aériens seront désormais gérés au
niveau national et des moyens
supplémentaires ont été annoncés pour
les 10 avec notamment
180 millions d'euros pour l'achat de
1100 engins et 500 sapeurs-pompiers
supplémentaires pour permettre une
meilleure adaptation de la forêt il est
prévu de débloquer les 150 premiers
millions d'euros pour le début de la
plantation du milliards d'arbres promis
par le Président de la République 40
millions seront également alloués à
l'ONF pour mieux préparer les forêts au
réchauffement climatique nous saluons
évidemment ces annonces du président de
la République mais nous attendons des
actes plus concrets
un rapport parlementaire sur le suivi
des engagements de la France pour le
climat pointe justement les nombreux
manquements et insuffisance
c'est ainsi la conclusion du Haut
Conseil pour le climat qui a souligné à
plusieurs reprises que le gouvernement
doit réduire les émissions au moins deux
fois plus vite nous espérons donc que ce
texte consensuel pour être adopté publié
avant l'été alors que la sécheresse de
cet hiver fait dès à présent peser le
risque de nouveaux feux de forêt de
grande ampleur cependant nous sommes
inquiets aujourd'hui car le gouvernement
vient de déposer des amendements de
suppression des articles 32 et 33 le
groupe Renaissance cherche également à
réduire drastiquement la portée de
l'article 34 l'adoption de ces
amendements ferait perdre au texte une
partie des apports initiaux voulu par le
Sénat et par les députés c'est pourquoi
le groupe Eder appelle à voter
favorablement ce texte tel qu'il a été
enrichi en commission sous réserve du
rejet des amendements de suppression du
gouvernement l'État devra ensuite
prendre ses responsabilités en termes de
moyens humains j'en ai presque fini
notamment et je tiens alors ici un
hommage appuyé sur leur dévouement et
leur courage mérité la reconnaissance de
la Nation merci de m'avoir écouté
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas Pacaud
pour le groupe Renaissance
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques mesdames
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues en 2022 72000 hectares de
terrain ont été incendiés sur notre
territoire soit 6 fois plus que la
moyenne des 10 dernières années est 50
départements ont été touchés par un feu
significatif
dépassant les zones traditionnelles de
vigilance y compris ma chère
Franche-Comté le fils National des
Forêts estiment par ailleurs que d'ici
la fin du siècle c'est l'ensemble du
territoire national qui sera concerné
par le risque incendie
la gravation des incendies s'explique
comme chacun le sait par les
conséquences du changement climatique
ainsi avec les sécheresses estivales que
nous connaissons les départs de feu ont
de plus en plus de chance de perdurer
ce phénomène n'est bien évidemment pas
propre à la France je pense évidemment à
nos amis canadiens et aux 30000
personnes qui ont été évacuées il y a
quelques jours de l'état de l'Alberta
dans ce contexte le Sénat a mis en place
dès le mois de mai 2022 une mission de
contrôle relative à la prévention et à
la lutte contre l'intensification et
l'extension du risque incendie cette
mission de contrôle entendait tirer les
leçons des retours d'expérience des feux
notamment après les épisodes
dévastateurs qui ont abrasé la Provence
en 2021 et la Gironde en juillet dernier
la proposition de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui on reprend les principales
conclusions
à l'issue de son examen en commission la
PPL contient une soixantaine d'articles
les principales mesures du texte se
déclinent en deux objectifs d'une part
prévenir les départs d'incendie
renforcer les obligations de
débroussaillement dans les forêts et à
leurs abords pré opter les parcelles de
forêt qui représentent en réseau d'un
défaut d'entretien un risque sérieux de
départ d'incendie créer une interdiction
de fumer dans les forêts à risque incité
les propriétaires forestiers à
entretenir leur parcelle en
conditionnant le religibilité aux aides
publiques à la mise en place des
documents de gestion de leur parcelle
d'autre part anticiper informé et
recenser les territoires à risque
élaborer une stratégie nationale de
défense des forêts en concertation avec
les acteurs concernés actualiser la
liste des territoires exposés au risque
d'incendie financés par la filière
reptaba des campagnes de communication
sur les risques en matière d'incendie
liés à l'abandon de mégots et inciter à
la mise en place de plan de prévention
des risques d'incendie de forêt la
proposition de loi en tant par ailleurs
remédier à des problèmes structurels en
matière de prévention et de gestion des
incendies en effet il faut
impérativement mieux articuler la
prévention des feux avec les autres
politiques publiques faire cesser les
injonctions contradictoires aux acteurs
de terrain qui se retrouvent parfois
confrontés à des arbitrages entre la
prévention des feux et la protection de
la biodiversité en somme définir une
politique publique
total est cohérente qui puisse
s'appliquer dans tous les territoires je
salue le travail des cinq rapports
Sophie panenacle Luc lamiro Anthony Bros
Sophie met Éric Poget qui bien qui suit
le groupe politique différent ont eu à
cœur de faire évoluer le texte dans un
esprit consensuel le groupe Renaissance
est bien sûr favorable à l'adoption de
cette proposition de loi nos amis
sénateurs auteurs de la présente
proposition de loi se sont fixés comme
objectif d'adopter ce texte avant l'été
et j'espère de tout cœur que nous débats
seront suffisamment apaisés et
constructif pour le permettre car il en
va de la protection de nos forêts de
notre faune et évidemment de nos
concitoyens
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Julien Rancourt
pour le groupe rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
mes chers collègues au nom du groupe
rassemblement national je tiens à saluer
en premier lieu le travail des sénateurs
à l'initiative de cette proposition de
loi visant à renforcer la prévention et
la lutte contre les feux de forêt et de
végétation plus largement
nous devons indéniablement prendre des
mesures pour repenser notre stratégie
contre la lutte incendie et plus
généralement renforcer notre sécurité
civile
si nous subissons à chaque année
d'importants incendies notamment dans le
sud de la France l'été 2022 aura été
particulièrement marquant et nous nous
devons d'en tirer les enseignements
nécessaires
tout d'abord l'ampleur de ces feux
parcourant pour certains plusieurs
milliers d'hectares
ce constat de tout évitant nous alerter
sur la gestion et l'entretien de nos
forêts
les moyens alloués à l'Office National
des Forêts ces dernières années ne sont
pas à la hauteur des enjeux
les communes notamment les communes
rurales doivent supporter des coûts non
négligeables que sont la gestion de
leurs espaces naturels ou encore
l'application d'un schéma communal de la
défense extérieure contre l'incendie
dans le même temps elle subissent de
plein fouet une hausse de leur charge de
fonctionnement en raison de l'inflation
et de la crise énergétique sans
augmentation significative de leur
dotation
j'en profite pour rappeler la
scandaleuse obstruction de Bruno Le
Maire et de Gabriel Attal le 5 mai
dernier pour que l'assemblée ne puisse
pas voter l'indexation de la DGF sur
l'inflation
évitez ces mégafeux c'est revoir notre
gestion de l'eau et œuvrer à la
réalisation de points d'eau tels que des
retenues colinéaires à proximité des
massifs forestiers sensibles c'est aussi
repasser notre forêt en réalisant de
nombreuses pistes
des coupes si nécessaire
quand bien même cela ne plaît pas à
certains pseudos écologistes qui s'y
oppose par pure idéologie on en a vu le
résultat l'été dernier avec les
terribles incendies dans les Landes qui
ont ravagé des dizaines de milliers
d'hectares
limiter la propagation des incendies
c'est aussi encourager et développer
notre agriculture notamment dans notre
viticulture et notre élevage qui rendent
véritables parfums naturels
une vigne arrachée un pâturage abandonné
c'est autant de friches vectrices
d'incendie supplémentaires
l'été 2022 aura été frappé par des feux
simultanés aux quatre coins du pays nous
obligeant même à demander des renforts
étrangers
car oui notre faute aérienne et
aujourd'hui plus suffisante pour assurer
nos besoins au regard des risques
actuels
les batailles perdues se résument en
deux mots trop tard
or n'avez-vous pas été n'avez-vous pas
un peu trop tardé
certes des annonces ont été faites après
la saison que nous venons de passer
mais les commandes de Canadair passées
ne seront livrés qu'en 2026 au mieux et
ne permettront que de remplacer ceux qui
arrivent déjà en fin de vie
pour rappel un 2022 sur les 12 canadairs
dont nous disposions seulement 8 étaient
opérationnels dont deux en maintenance
en plein été uniquement pour des raisons
budgétaires car il était plus coûteux de
tous les faire vérifier hors saison
estivale
idem pour les dash ou sur nos 7
appareils seul 5 était disponible
et les moyens annoncés en location sont
certes une bonne nouvelle mais elles ne
sont pas une solution pérenne
les services départementaux d'incendie
de secours quant à eux prennent en
charge les défaillances de l'État sur
les finances des départements et des
communes
certains départements aux revenus
modestes comme l'Aude se trouve
confronté à des risques incendies élevés
et doivent investir chaque année dans du
matériel coûteux
la TICPE taxe sur les carburants
représentent plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros en moins sur leur
budget la proposition de loi présentée
aujourd'hui prévoit son exonération
sans aucune concertation le gouvernement
est déposé un amendement de suppression
sur ce dispositif
mesdames et messieurs de la majorité
vous expliquerez aux sapeurs-pompiers de
votre département qu'ils n'auront pas de
nous de nouveaux équipements
supplémentaires nécessaires parce que
vous avez refusé cette exonération de
taxe
l'ensemble des oppositions je l'espère
vous mettre en échec sur ce point
ceci étant dit il va sans dire que nous
voterons favorablement ce texte trans
partisan tout en proposant des
améliorations notables au fil des débats
tels que la création d'un délégué
interministériel dédié
un meilleur encadrement pour inciter les
entreprises à recruter des
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires ou encore
des mesures de bon sens pour la
protection globale de nos forêts cette
proposition de loi ne doit pas être ne
doit être qu'un premier pas à la fois
dans la modernisation de notre sécurité
civile et la gestion de nos forêts et
espaces naturels je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Florian chaud
pour le groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le Président des affaires
économiques Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteur chers collègues
je crois qu'il y a une prise de
conscience collective à la suite des
incendies survenu à l'été 2022 une prise
de conscience des conséquences du
changement climatique
on en a vu des incendies on a vu des
incendies dans le Finistère dans le Jura
voisins de ma circonscription ce qui
n'était jamais arrivé de mémoire d'homme
50 départements touchés par des
incendies des terres daigniers l'été
dernier
nous avons vu ce que signifiait
concrètement l'extension géographique du
risque incendie et cette année encore
avec un incendie de plus de 1000
hectares en avril dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales départements
aujourd'hui placé en crise sécheresse
nous commençons à réaliser que ce qui
était exceptionnel est en train de
devenir la norme à la lecture des titres
de cette proposition de cette
proposition de loi il n'y a pas un mot à
changer prévention régulation
amélioration sensibilisation équipement
et financement tout un programme
malheureusement cela ne se traduit pas
de manière proportionnelle dans le
contenu de la loi certes cette
proposition de loi contient des
dispositions pertinentes et attendues je
pense notamment aux nouveaux pouvoirs
accordés au préfet ou à l'élaboration
d'une stratégie nationale et
interministérielle de défense des forêts
contre les incendies ou encore à la
construction d'une approche à l'échelle
du massif qui apparaît pertinente
l'application du monde agricole est
également à saluée au regard de
l'accroissement du risque de feux de
surface agricole enfin je me réjouis de
voir figurer dans cette proposition de
loi des mesures réclamées de longues
dates par nos 10 comme l'exonération de
TICPE et de malus écologique cependant
je ne peux que regretter l'absence de
vision globale et les trois tests de
certaines mesures on nous parle
d'équiper la lutte incendie à l'auteur
du risque mais qu'en est-il des moyens
humains seuls les sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires sont évoqués et quelle
mesure propose-t-on pour remédier à la
crise du volontariat et suscité de
l'engagement l'exonération de cotisation
patronales pour sensibiliser la
population risque incendie que nous
proposons ici une journée nationale de
la résilience et l'interdiction de fumer
dans les bois et forêts drôles de
conception de la sensibilisation et de
la prévention la présence proposition de
loi n'apporte donc que des solutions
palliatives nous comblons certaines
lacunes nous mettons des pansements sur
certaines blessures mais il n'y a pas de
planification c'est une ambition sans
moyens c'est donc peu de choses
pourtant nos forces de sécurité civile
mériteraient mieux un sapeur-pompier m'a
dit en France on agit toujours après la
crise quand tout va bien on ne fait rien
et force cette constater qu'il a fallu
que nous approchions de la rupture
capacitaire pour que le gouvernement se
décide à prendre des mesures alors on
nous annonce à renouvellement de la
flottérienne mais la vérité c'est que le
premier Canada n'arrivera pas avant 208
la vérité c'est qu'en 2010 déjà un
rapport de la Mission interministérielle
relative au changement climatique
préconisé un renforcement des moyens
aériens résultat les recommandations
n'ont pas été suivies le dimensionnement
de la flotte n'a pas augmenté depuis les
années 80 alors que le risque hier
circonscrit circonscrit pardon ou
pourtour méditerranéen s'est étendu à
l'ensemble du territoire
la triste vérité c'est qu'en 2002 nous
pouvions compter sur 5117 camions
citerne feu de forêt pour lutter contre
les incendies et que nous n'en avons
plus que 3845 en 2020 et ceci est le
résultat de décision politique comme
celle prise par le gouvernement en 2020
du retrait de l'État en matière de
soutien aux dépenses d'investissement
des 10 pire encore le président de la
République se contente de faire de la
communication politique en annonçant
vouloir replanter un milliard d'arbres
en disant qu'en est-il de l'interdiction
des couperase qu'en est-il du mélange
des essences et de la régénération
naturelle des forêts et comment faire
confiance à un gouvernement qui n'a
cessé de diminuer les effectifs de
l'Office National des Forêts amputées de
militives équivalents temps plein entre
2014 et 2022
du côté des moyens humains si nous
voulons solutionner la crise du
volontariat si nous voulons susciter de
l'engagement et permettre à nos
sapeurs-pompiers de disposer de temps
pour se former à la lutte contre les
feux de forêt il va aussi falloir les
repositionner sur leur cœur de métier
aujourd'hui plus de 20% des
interventions réalisées par nos
sapeurs-pompiers ne relève pas du
secours d'urgence et ne relèvent donc
pas de leur mission le ministère de
l'Intérieur et de la santé doivent se
mettre autour d'une table afin de
trouver des solutions on ne peut plus
accepter qu'un véhicule de secours est
quatre sapeurs-pompiers attendent
plusieurs heures qu'un patient soit pris
en charge à l'hôpital la case de
l'hôpital et des services publics de
manière plus générale affecte nos
sapeurs-pompiers qui jouent le rôle de
supplétif d'un système de soins à bout
de souffle dans beaucoup de nos
territoires les pompiers sont les
derniers services publics de proximité
trop longtemps l'État n'a pas donné de
moyens humains et financiers suffisant à
la sécurité civile au-delà du risque
incendie c'est l'ensemble des événements
climatiques extrêmes qui vont être plus
fréquents et plus intenses sécheresse
inondations épisode de grêle les années
à venir vont être éprouvantes le risque
augmente les scientifiques l'ont annoncé
nos pompiers le constatent sur le
terrain aujourd'hui c'est à nous
décideurs politiques des Tao et d'être à
la hauteur des enjeux pour le moment le
compte n'y est pas
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Michel
Castellani pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoire
le gouvernement donc fait le choix de
présenter en avril dernier un plan de
lutte contre les incendies nous ne
pouvons accueillir favorablement les
annonces qui ont été faites à cette
occasion les ministres en charge ont
exprimé leur volonté d'augmenter les
moyens humains et matériels par la
création de cette colonne de renfort
supplémentaire un nouveau groupe d'appui
du génie par des renforts d'avions et
des hélicoptères bombardiers d'eau bien
que la compétence 10 relève des
départements nous jugeons que l'État les
accompagne dans l'achat de nouveaux
véhicules à travers un soutien financier
de 180 millions d'euros il est
indispensable que l'État et des
collectivités poursuivent cette
mobilisation afin de donner des moyens
suffisants aux femmes et hommes qui
opèrent de leur vie sauve les nôtres
protègent nos biens et sauvegarde de
notre biodiversité
sur le plus long terme en revanche les
moyens ne sont pas garantis il manque
notamment la planification concernant
l'achat de matériel je pense bien sûr
plus particulièrement aux outils
complexes comme les avions bombardent
des eaux le principal fabricant Canadair
a stoppé la production d'appareils on le
sait aussi notre groupe considère
nécessaire de donner de la visibilité
aux industriels afin qu'ils relancent
leur chaîne de production en prévoyant
une programmation pluriannuelle des
investissements en matière de lutte
contre les incendies dans le cas des
Canadairs c'est une commande groupée
européenne qui permettra à de nouveaux
avions de sortir d'usine à partir de
autre difficulté le déficit de moyens de
l'ONF les incendies ont mis en lumière
l'émission primordiale des salariés et
fonctionnaires à l'organisation entre
gestion prévention anticipation pourtant
l'établissement public subit une vente
d'érosion de ses moyens et effectifs
depuis plusieurs décennies je veux aussi
insister sur un point fondamental le
manque de moyens et rien léger bien sûr
l'achat de Canadair est une bonne
nouvelle mais des avions plus petits
moins chers mais plus nombreux après
plusieurs années à de nombreux endroits
du territoire sont aussi importants dans
la stratégie de lutte que nous devons
bâtir comme de nombreux territoires du
sud de la France à la Corse aimerait
pouvoir compter sur une base permanente
d'aéronef dédiée à la lutte contre les
incendies ou à défaut de moins
supplémentaires ce qui d'ailleurs sera
le cas pour la saison qui arrive dans
cette optique nous pourrions aussi
explorer les avantages des partenariats
publics privés comme le c'est une
pratique chez certains de nos voisins
européens
je veux le rappeler lors du débat du
mois de novembre dernier Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur nous avait donné
la garantie en réponse à un de mes
amendements repris par le gouvernement
que les moyens de lutte encore ça serait
conservés renforcés je vais remercier le
ministre et je le remercie encore comme
j'avais fait alors je renouvelle
également ma demande que des Canadairs
soient positionnés à Bastia poeta je
souligne à nouveau l'excellence de la
situation de Bastia en Méditerranée
occidentale et la sûreté exceptionnelle
du site je vous demande de jeter un œil
à une carte et vous comprendrez le bien
fondé de ma requête le souci qui m'anime
et bien sûr celui d'une optimisation
dans l'attaque des feux la rapidité
d'intervention étant un élément premier
d'efficacité ceci encore c'est comme
hors de l'île
j'en viens à cette proposition de loi
notre groupe l'accueille favorablement
en ce qu'elle porte des mesures
essentielles parmi les mesures phares
figurent le renforcement des obligations
légales de débroussaillement cet axe est
essentiel pour limiter les départs de
feu et défendre les habitations autre
mesure forte la consécration au niveau
de la loi de l'interdiction de fumer
dans une forêt exposer un risque
d'incendie et le renforcement des
sanctions en cas de gel de mégot à noter
tout de même que ces mesures n'auront
des faits que s'ils peuvent être
contrôlées par des gardes forestiers
aujourd'hui en nombre insuffisant nous
sommes également favorables à la mise en
place d'un dispositif de réduction de
cotisations patronales pour les
employeurs en contrepartie de la
disponibilité de leurs employés
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires c'est un
premier pas pour donner de
l'attractivité au volontariat je
terminerai donc en disant que notre
groupe portera plusieurs amendements qui
est enrichir un test que vous l'aurez
compris nous soutiendrons au regard de
ces apports pour la sécurité de nos
concitoyens et de la préservation de
l'environnement je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Frédéric ginski
pour le groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
des affaires économiques Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs
à 15h il faisait noir comme en pleine
nuit
comme des nuages très très bas mais de
fumée
à Bordeaux à 30 km d'ici descendre
retombées en ville et sur la route les
gens fuyaient à pied à vélo en voiture
comme l'exode de la guerre
ces paroles sont celles de Christian
Giraudeau qui avait 14 ans lorsque
l'incendie du siècle en 1949 à Cestas
ville dont je suis l'élu dans le massif
des langues de Gascogne
les flammes ont emporté ces deux
camarades de classe
et 80 autres personnes dont 23
militaires du 33e régiment d'artillerie
de Châtellerault et le maire de Saucats
Roger Giraudeau
dans ma ville de Cestas donc on
commémorons cette tragédie au mois
d'août devant un monument dédié aux
victimes
ce tornade de feu est l'un des premiers
cas d'embrasement généralisé éclairent à
ciel ouvert ce sont 52 000 hectares
partis en fumée en 6 jours
cette catastrophe humaine et écologique
intervenaient deux ans après la création
d'un corps spécifique de
sapeurs-pompiers forestier professionnel
qui faisait suite à une dure décennie de
sécheresse et de feux de forêt
1949 allait donner une accélération
spectaculaire à la prévention
faisant de la plus grande forêt cultivée
d'Europe l'une des mieux entretenues et
des plus sécurisés
pourtant depuis cette date ce sont
encore des centaines de milliers
d'hectares qui sont partis en fumée
le changement climatique ne promet pas
des jours meilleurs
dans le sixième rapport d'évaluation sur
le changement climatique les experts du
GIEC prévoient une hausse de la
probabilité de feux de forêt de portée
catastrophique comprises entre 30 et 60%
d'ici la fin du siècle selon les
scénarios d'évolution des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre
les feux s'intensifieront et cet endroit
dans l'espace et dans le temps avec la
multiplication des périodes de
sécheresse les terres agricoles
elles-mêmes seront de plus en plus
vulnérables
le président de la Fédération nationale
des sapeurs-pompiers de France rappelant
à ce titre que désormais la saison des
feux c'est toute l'année
cette guerre contre le feu ne sera gagné
qu'au prix d'un effort impliquant toutes
les politiques publiques faisant une
plus large part à la prévention
face à ce cumul des défis climatiques
économique et sécuritaire le Sénat nous
propose une stratégie de prévention nous
saluons le renforcement de l'obligation
légale de débroussaillement la
dynamisation de la gestion sylvicole la
sécurisation des travaux des
agriculteurs mais aussi une meilleure
sensibilisation des citoyens ainsi
qu'une incitation à la mise à
disposition des sapeurs-pompiers
volontaires
toutefois nous souhaitons mettre
l'accent sur la nécessité d'élaborer des
stratégies et des outils adaptés aux
spécificités de chaque territoire c'est
pourquoi nous porterons un amendement
afin de soumettre la carte identifiant
la sensibilité au danger prévisible des
feux de forêt et de végétation du
territoire européen de la France à la
vie de la direction départementale des
territoires et de la Chambre
départementale d'agriculture
la proposition de loi que nous étudions
aujourd'hui visent également à adapter
les diverses législations applicables
aux acteurs de la lutte contre les
incendies au premier rang desquels les
pompiers mais aussi la DFCI qui joue un
rôle majeur notamment en Aquitaine
ce qui permettra d'accroître leur
capacité de répondre à la hauteur du
risque
c'est pourquoi nous soutenons toute
mesure visant à donner des marges de
manœuvre supplémentaires tant financière
coopérationnel
OS 10 nous appelons également de nos
vœux la réalisation d'un état des lieux
des outils des dispositifs existants
afin de faciliter le recrutement de
sapeurs-pompiers volontaires tant pour
les entreprises que pour les services
départementaux d'incendie et de secours
cet état des lieux nous permettra
d'identifier les lacunes existantes et
ainsi à terme les options qui pourront
être mises en œuvre tels que les
contrats d'apprentissage et d'alternance
par exemple
car oui nous ne serons nous ne serons
jamais suffisamment nombreux pour
protéger les poumons de notre planète et
en soutenant l'adoption de ce texte le
groupe démocrate salut l'engagement de
tous ces protecteurs
que nos forêts puissent encore pour
longtemps nous faire respirer et nous
inspirer je vous remercie
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Emmanuelle Ménard
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues faut-il rappeler la
violence et la brutalité des incendies
qu'on connu l'Europe et la France en
2022 près de 800000 hectares parti en
fumée entre le premier janvier et le 19
novembre soit le double de la moyenne
annuelle des 15 dernières années triste
record même chose pour la France où les
mégafeux ont détruit plus de 72000
hectares l'an dernier sur l'ensemble de
notre territoire pendant des jours et
des nuits des centaines d'hommes et de
femmes ont combattu pied à pied héroïque
depuis les heures et sur terre ses feux
hors normes qui ont bat la Fresnes aux
paysages et réduit en cendres des forêts
parfois centenaires le constat est
accablant et je profite de cette
occasion pour rendre un hommage appuyé à
tous nos pompiers professionnels et
volontaires dont le dévouement a été
sans faille comme il les chaque jour de
l'année lorsqu'il s'agit de venir à
notre secours j'ai également une pensée
pour Jérémy Beyer c'était déjà
face à ce risque devenu une quasi
certitude le gouvernement a annoncé le
11 avril dernier plus de moyens pour
lutter contre les feux de forêt le
ministre de l'Intérieur s'y était engagé
dès l'été dernier en promettant de
mettre à disposition davantage de
bombardiers d'eau et d'engins terrestres
de pompiers et de militaires et
d'allouer 180 millions d'euros aux 10
afin d'acquérir 1100 véhicules de lutte
contre le feu espérons que les mesures
annoncées suffiront à nous faire passer
l'été elle part en tout cas au plusieurs
gens car c'est bien d'argent qu'il
s'agit aussi dans l'Hérault le 10 a
enregistré en 2022 un déficit historique
de près de 1,8 millions d'euros la
hausse exponentielle des incendies a
coûté 3 millions de plus qu'en 2021 avec
638 incendies pour 1525 hectares de
végétation détruits on a compté presque
10 000 interventions de plus entre
janvier et septembre 2022 que par
rapport à la même période en 2021
ajouter à cela les dépenses de carburant
900000 euros de plus que prévu soit une
hausse de
29%, l'addition est salée c'est vous
dire si l'amendement de suppression de
l'article 32 par le gouvernement
concernant la suppression de la
fiscalité sur les carburants des
pompiers et mal accueilli des coûts
essentiellement supportés par les
départements ou avec l'aide des communes
lorsque comme c'est le cas à Béziers une
nouvelle caserne va voir le jour qui
sera également financé par la Ville le
terrain sera fourni plus 2,2 millions
d'euros sur les 11 que Coutras la
caserne au finale il faut le souligner
le texte que nous étudions aujourd'hui
fruit des conclusions de la mission de
contrôle du Sénat était particulièrement
attendu les actions de prévention
notamment qui sont essentielles comme
l'obligation de débroussaillage qu'il
faut rendre effective pourquoi ne pas
généraliser en outre aux abords des
stations d'autoroute les asperceurs
d'eau déjà utilisés dans les
Bouches-du-Rhône du bon sens me
semble-t-il la population également doit
être mieux armée pour faire face aux
incendies en adoptant les bons gestes
lorsque les habitations sont menacées et
puis comment accepter que encore de nos
jours des incendies soient déclenchés
par de simples mégots jetés dans la
nature ces comportements doivent être
plus que jamais durement sanctionner
lorsque leurs auteurs sont retrouvés il
faut le rappeler
90% des départs de feu sont causés par
l'homme et 30% sont volontaires selon
l'Office National des Forêts l'article
34 de ce masque de ce texte devait
également marquer un tournant important
réclamé par l'ensemble des volontaires
du public ou du privé et de leurs
employeurs cette mesure devait permettre
en effet d'exonérer au titre d'une
expérimentation sur trois ans les
cotisations à la charge de l'employeur
pour chaque salarié sapeur-pompier
volontaire employés dans la limite de
3000 euros par an et par volontaire et
de 15000 euros au total un début de
réponse nous l'espérions tous à la crise
du volontariat constaté depuis quelques
années maintenant
c'était sans compter sur l'amendement
546 du gouvernement qui revient sur
cette disposition et qui je l'espère
sera rejetée vous l'avez compris je
voterai ce texte d'autant plus si les
amendements du Gouvernement que j'ai
cités sont rejetés afin de ne pas
dénaturer ce texte dont nos
sapeurs-pompiers ont tellement besoin je
vous remercie
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
la discussion générale et close